the jurgen experience
that could be a thing like you know like
they used to have duels so if a duel was
like two guys would agree like i [ __ ]
you annoy me so much i'm gonna get a gun
and we're gonna back to back we're gonna
walk 10 feet and shoot at each other
[ __ ] you like you're ready to die maybe
you'll shoot me but i'm going to [ __ ]
at least be able to shoot you like a man
and we're going to go and do this
they agreed to do that
100 years ago i think i'm not long ago
well wasn't at least one of our
presidents involved in something like
that i think so but if i can't remember
who or any deals behind it
one of our presidents was in a duel
right while he was president do you
remember who was killed alexander
hamilton really that was like the whole
thing but was he even president hold on
no alexander hamilton died in a duel
uh
hamilton wasn't president remember we
talked about him the other day drink
milk commercials like aaron burr eric i
can't say aaron burger
huh there's an old milk commercial from
the 90s it was a great radio call who
like if you answer this question you win
a million dollars right who killed
alexander hamilton they call like the
alexander hamilton guy he's got all this
[ __ ] in his apartment and he's mountains
full of a peanut butter jelly sandwich
you can't say aaron burr
oh
right yeah that's right i forgot about
that commercial uh but as i'm saying it
out loud i feel like he wasn't president
no he wasn't we talked about the other
day remember someone brought up that who
was it that brought that up that he had
gotten
uh
blackmailed andrew jackson maybe
did he kill him but he got
but hamilton got blackmailed because he
he was banging this lady and her and her
husband set him up remember right yes
that's the play who talked to us about
that it was real recently
it was one of the recent guests
who the [ __ ] was it omar
was it probably it might have been sound
like something he would talk about
how many of these you do two or three
podcasts a week sometimes four
sometimes five on a crazy week yeah
and how much do in comedy
um
this week four
four four nights a week by the way your
show your show killed it when i was out
there last time yeah and all your
openers you had great guys too president
andrew jackson thank you may 30th 1806
future president andrew jackson kills a
man who accused him of cheating on a
horse race bet
and then insulted his wife rachel wow i
think he had a lot of duels
oh he had a lot of duels yeah a few
duels no big deal more than a hundred
what can you imagine biden or trump
doing a duel yes what not every duel
ended and i remember looking this up not
everyone ended someone dying click on
that of course they have terrible guns
their guns are terrible you could
probably duel that's just insane that's
insane he was a savage i think he even
had one where he got shot and and uh
survived the shooting to end up shooting
that guy back whoa look at our
presidents now we had guys like that and
teddy teddy roosevelt and now uh did you
see the video today of biden uh he
starts talking about afghanistan and
pakistan and an easter bunny comes and
takes him away
i'm looking that up after the show i'll
show it to you
it's just the funny part people can't
admit something's wrong with them look
at this but hold on go right there but
jackson didn't settle the score in 140
characters or less he challenged his
foes to duels of more than a hundred of
them one opponent even died so he only
killed one guy but that was a guy who
insulted his wife however for the most
part people would stand and fire their
gun in the air purposefully miss their
opponent making the duel more about a
test of courage when one's honor was at
stake or their reputation was threatened
oh that's interesting if you back down
then you're you know giant [ __ ] but you
don't shoot at each other like you make
a deal like barely i'm not gonna shoot
you
maybe that's what you were hoping
yeah that's a [ __ ] that's quite quite
a risk-a-take that's a big risk hope joe
doesn't shoot me in our door yeah we
were i insulted rachel but does it say
there again scroll up it says not every
time jackson lost his cool with a gun in
his hand was is documented but here are
four that helped him
helped give him his reputation as a rage
field lunatic and a few that left his
body rattling like a bag of marbles oh
so he had like that was the thing if you
got shot back then the velocity of those
little muskets that's not like getting
shot today
i don't think those things are going
that fast you're probably less like uh
less likely to die you might be able to
catch one
and this is the guy they selected as
president so things have always been
crazy apparently yeah
that's a wild dude with his pistols but
back then i feel like gunfights are
probably pretty normal you know yeah
someone insults you might go shoot it
out and maybe they will become again so
when that's when did it stop
when they've stopped yeah probably like
in the 1900s or early 1900s maybe world
war one
brought everybody together but if you
think of the united states and you go to
the 1800s what do you think of you think
of wild west think of gunfights if you
think in new york city you think of
gangs in new york right
here's the one i would i remember
reading about this he had gotten shot
close to his heart and still had
the wherewithal too within a few seconds
dixon fired dickinson fired putting the
first bullet into jackson's chest next
to his heart jackson put his hand over
the wound to staunch the flow of blood
despite smoke and dust billowing from
jackson's coat and his hand touching his
chest jackson remains standing puzzling
dickinson my god have i missed him the
duels protocol required
stated that a protocol required stated
that dickinson to remain in place while
jackson aimed to take his shot jackson
fired but the flint hammer stopped half
cocked not counting as a legitimate shot
jackson aimed again
ever so carefully and fired a second
time this time the shot was good and the
bullet hit dickinson in the chest and he
dropped to the ground reflecting on the
duel the doctor remarked to jackson i
don't see how you stayed on your feet
after that wound to which jackson
responded i would have stood up long
enough to kill him
if he had put a bullet in my brain
whoa
it's a hardcore man
that's that's a president right there
yeah right
things sure have changed he died later
that night jackson was not prosecuted
for murder and dickinson would be the
only man he ever killed in duel
something that did not prevent him from
becoming president in 1829
wow people might not have believed the
story either too you know how that story
would not maybe not got around right
there's no video yeah
yeah it's hard you got to be accountable
to duels today i already killed someone
right he had more than a
kills yeah a hundred duels like he might
be an [ __ ] right like how many people
he's arguing with to the point where
they're pulling guns out that's a lot a
hundred right maybe like two or three
maybe it's uh maybe it's them it's 100
it's probably you but he
if he's famous he probably was getting
challenged a lot too you know people
were drunk at a bar there's that andrew
jackson yeah with shitty booze too
imagine how bad their whiskey tasted oh
yeah like look there's just a group of
guys and they're like [ __ ] i'll [ __ ]
fight them yeah they're probably so
bored they'll fight anybody back then
no tv no internet oh and everybody
smelled
no soap
right everybody stunk everybody has been
so gross teeth were rotting out their
[ __ ] heads
oh my god you imagine living back then
everybody must have stunk yeah well
things were so bad people be like hey
let's just try like trucking across to
the other part of the country we have no
idea and a wagon we might we might get
killed by indians bears yeah they would
fly
or rather uh sail in from across the
ocean
not even knowing what's out there yeah
no idea probably gonna die but better
than staying here